vous
bonsoir le 7 8 en direct à 18h du lundi
au jeudi une heure pour faire le point
sur l'actualité du département des
yvelines nous parlerons notamment
culture ce soir dans un quart d'heure la
chronique culture avec johanna soudry
auparavant je vous propose de découvrir
le sommaire de cette édition en images
le les principaux titres un sujet
gourmand avec le portrait de thibaut
ruggieri à 30 ans ce chef à l'école
lenôtre à plaisir participera fin
janvier aux championnats du monde des
cuisiniers nous avons suivi la
préparation de ces plans deux premiers
contrats d'avenir signée dans les
yvelines attrape au sein de l'entreprise
d'insertion envie dans le département
1600 contrat de ce type devrait être
conclu le directeur de la mission locale
la de saint-quentin-en-yvelines est en
plateau pour nous en dire plus mois de
novembre mois des plantations dans ce
domaine national de marly à 222 tilleuls
sont plantés à terme ce sont 5000 arbres
qui vont revenir peupler le lieu royal
il chante en ukrainien uniquement en
ukrainien une chorale particulière qui
existe depuis 10 ans maintenant à
guyancourt est sous la houlette de leur
chef de choeur vasile boris il sera là
lui aussi sur ce plateau et puis à noter
que nous parlerons aussi de la journée
mondiale de lutte contre le sida prévue
le 1er décembre en plateau je recevrai
germandrée le président da chef
prévention l'association basée sur
villepreux on passe donc au fait du jour
est à ces fameux emplois d'avenir
accessible aux jeunes peu qualifiés
depuis le début du mois de novembre les
emplois d'avenir vise à fournir une
première expérience professionnelle pour
quel public et à quelles conditions
alors que le chômage explose encore au
mois d'octobre avec les chiffres qui ont
été communiqués hier plus de 45000
nouveaux demandeurs d'emploi sur le mois
d'octobre
là nous allons poser la question à
françois chaumette bonsoir vous êtes
donc le directeur de la mission locale
de saint quentin en yvelines et de ses
environs les emplois d'avenir est ce que
ce sont est-ce que c'est cette formule
une recette miracle c'est pas une
recette miracle mais je pense que c'est
un nouveau dispositif qui est très
intéressant et qui se démarque des
autres contrats aidés qu'on peut
connaître les contrées der pour rappel
vise à effectuer une discrimination
positive vis-à-vis de certains publics
ayant des difficultés particulières
d'accès à l'emploi pour permettre
justement c'est cet accès là on est dans
un tout autre type de contrat ou le
centre est où le jeune est au centre de
ce contrat l'objectif étant que durant
les trois ans que peuvent durée d'un an
près d'avenir le jeune progresse suivent
une formation et que ces contrats lui
sert de tremplin pour après soit rester
dans l'entreprise qui va l'accueillir
soit après être mieux armé pour
rechercher un nouvel emploi
on va découvrir ensemble chiffre du jour
le chiffre de cette édition de tout
simplement c'est le nombre d'emplois
d'avenir signée dans le département des
yvelines attrape au sein de l'entreprise
d'insertion envie ce sont d'ailleurs les
deux premiers emplois d'avenir qui ont
été signés à le ministre benoît hamon
ministre de l'économie sociale et
solidaire étaient présents reportage de
valérie auribeau et de guillaume kampf
grosse pression ce soir au sein de
l'association d'insertion envie attrape
c'est en présence d'un ministre est sous
les feux des projecteurs que ces deux
jeunes filles signent leurs emplois
d'avenir
les premiers du département avant les
1600 à venir pour cette année avec
l'uriné cet ep est content parce que
j'ai jamais
ainsi assuré la ministre c'est beau
chien sur l'autre ce contrat d'avenir
que j'ai signé aujourd'hui c'est un
poste de secrétaire comptable donc en
cdi donc après j'aurai droit à une
formation heureuse grâce à ce contrat la
formation de paye de comptabilité
ces emplois d'avenir sont l'une des
réponses du gouvernement pour réduire le
chômage des jeunes ce sont des cdi ou
des cdd de trois ans il s'adresse aux 16
25 ans peu ou pas qualifiés et les
formations peuvent aller jusqu'à bac +3
en échange de cette embauche
les entreprises sont exonérées en partie
de charges sociales et sur les contrats
de travail qui permet déjà de se
projeter dans l'avenir c'est du temps
plein c'est minimum au smic ne connaît
pas sur contrat
au rabais au passage benoît hamon
inaugure la première antenne pour
l'ile-de-france du réseau envie
entreprise de réinsertion positionner
sur le recyclage d'appareils
électroménagers le ministre souhaite
booster l'économie sociale et solidaire
notamment dans les yvelines et rappelle
que les entreprises de le ss ont été
plus robuste dans la crise que les
entreprises du capital et ont
généralement une durée de vie plus
longue
le réseau envie existe depuis plus de 20
ans l'antenne de trappes emploie
aujourd'hui 17 salariés dont onze
personnes en réinsertion
c'est donc l'antenne envie à trappes qui
bénéficient de ces deux premiers emplois
d'avenir là on est véritablement dans le
bon registre puisque c'est une
association d'insertion également donc
voilà c'est exactement le cadre idéal
pour lancer ses premiers emplois de oui
je trouve qu'on est vraiment tout à fait
dans la philosophie des emplois d'avenir
quand on connaît un petit peu les deux
jeunes qui ont signé ces contrats est ce
que leur propose en vie on est vraiment
sûr du mu sur du sur mesure par rapport
à là où en est la jeune et il a où
l'entreprise a envie de les emmener avec
l'appui de la mission le cas puisque on
en parlera tout à l'heure les missions
locales vont assurer tout un
accompagnement du jeune pendant le
contrat si on reprend un petit peu il a
été proposé deux choses différentes à
ces jeunes a une qui a une formation de
bac en secrétariat
cette entreprise souhaite la garder don
qui lui étaient proposées non pas comme
ça sera souvent pour les emplois
d'avenir a fait d'aider mais un cdi avec
vraiment l'objectif de les faire suivre
un certain nombre de formations en
interne mais surtout des modules en
externe pendant cet emploi plus pour
qu'à terme elles sont capables d'occuper
seul un poste de secrétariat et de
comptabilité
l'autre jeune qui est une jeune qui
avait un bon niveau dans son pays
initial les indes qui avaient une
licence en informatique est arrivé en
france il ya deux ans de par l'offre de
formation linguistique elle n'a pas
beaucoup plus progresser en français on
l'a vu lula à l'oral ça va aller crise
est un petit peu plus difficile
donc elle a un bon niveau initial mais
qu'elle est totalement incapable de
valoriser sur le marché du travail en
france ici et là en vie lui a proposé un
contrat de 18 mois avec comme objectif
clair 1 d'une part d'être en situation
de parler le français
huit heures par jour en occupant son
poste et de travailler sur son projet
professionnel et sur un projet
professionnel plus ambitieux que un
poste d'entretien et on a entendu en
plus elle était ravie de rencontrer le
ministre a glissé qui était assise à
côté d'elle
le ministre benoît hamon qui précisait
dans l'interview qu'on a entendues au
cours du reportage également que ce
n'était pas des contrats au rabais
véritablement les emplois d'avenir et
c'est ça qui change peut-être un petit
peu avec les les autres formules on est
sur une base d'un de vrais contrats
pourtant que ça veut dire quelque chose
oui par rapport à d'autres contrats
aidés on est là sur un contrat qui est
prévu pour durer trois ans qui est un
plat temps qui est rémunéré au minimum
le smic mais ça peut être plus donc
c'est vrai que c'est aussi un contrat
qui permet aux jeunes de se stabiliser
de faire des projets etc
on n'est pas dans la précarité des cae
qui dure six mois qui éventuellement
seront renouvelés ou non on va continuer
à expliquer à qui s'adressent ces
emplois d'avenir une petite précision
tout de même il y en aura deux types
pour le secteur marchand et le secteur
non marchand oui c'est à dire alors
aujourd'hui je parlais des emplois
d'avenir dans le secteur non marchand
par secteurs non marchands dont on
entend les associations les
collectivités territoriales
aussi quelques organismes de droit
public tels que les hôpitaux par exemple
ou des organismes de droit privé
assurant une mission de service public
elle a par contre les services de l'état
ne pourront pas embaucher dans pleins
d'avenir
il y aura aussi un volet emplois
d'avenir dans le secteur marchand mais
là les métiers des secteurs qui seront
éligibles à ces emplois d'avenir seront
déterminés par un arrêté du préfet de
région qui n'est pas encore sorti donc
je ne vais pas en parler on va
s'intéresser de son cas dans le secteur
non marchand ces emplois d'avenir
quelles sont les modalités pour
participer pour en bénéficier alors déjà
je pense qu'il faut définir le public
qui peut en bénéficier du coup ça permet
aussi de définir les postes qui peuvent
être proposées ces emplois d'avenir sont
vraiment destiné à des jeunes de bas
niveaux de qualification
c'est à dire prioritairement des jeunes
ayant un niveau inférieur au bac c'est
sûr qu'ils ont pu aller gestion terminal
mais ne pas l'obtenir
et puis aussi à des jeunes qui ont
obtenu un crp ou un bep donc qui est un
diplôme professionnel mais dans ces cas
là ils doivent avoir six mois de
recherche d'emploi dans les 12 derniers
mois et à titre dérogatoire est donc
vraiment là exceptionnelle s'est aussi
ouvert à des jeunes qui habite en zus et
qu'il a peuvent avoir un niveau jusqu'à
bas que ce soit donc licence mais à
condition d'avoir aussi douze mois de
recherche d'emploi dans les 18 derniers
en zone urbaine sensible quartier où
c'est vrai que les jeunes y compris des
jeunes qualifiés ont des difficultés
particulières d'accès à l'emploi dans
vos missions locales vous oeuvrez
justement à l'insertion de de tous ces
jeunes est ce que vous parlez vous
présentait déjà ce dispositif qui est
une vingtaine de jours oui alors on
commence en parler on ne veut vraiment
voulu attendre d'avoir les derniers
textes des circulaires sont parus le 31
octobre
il ya eu des cas là jusqu'à la fin donc
on a attendu que les circulaires soit
bien bien arrêtées on commence à en
parler on commence à recueillir des
offres on fait surtout un gros travail
de sensibilisation vis-à-vis des
employeurs potentiels qui aussi découvre
ce nouveau contrat qui est vraiment
nouveau qui ont vraiment besoin
d'explications de s'approprier les
tenants et les aboutissants de ce
contrat est habituellement ils y voient
un réel intérêt
voilà alors que l on peut se le dire
quand même on est aussi dans un contexte
budgétaire ou les associations les
collectivités territoriales ont des
contraintes fortes et spontanément
n'avais pas envie d'entamer une
réflexion sur ces emplois d'avenir mais
quand on leur présente ses nouveaux
emplois qui vraiment je pense sont une
chance et pour les jeunes et pour les
entreprises accueillent et on peut en
parler par effet induit pour les
missions locales y sont sensibles à divo
un intérêt les jeunes les employeurs
commencent à bien connaître ce
dispositif qui se met tout juste en
place que c'est ce que le grand public a
eu connaissance de ces emplois d'avenir
est ce que vous en avez déjà entendu
parler qu'en savez-vous c'est la
question que nous sommes allez vous
poser aujourd'hui je ne sais pas si
c'est des emplois pour
pour les jeunes ou des espaces et des
petits boulots non les petits je sais
pas si c'est lié aux affaires ou comment
dirais-je aux économies d'énergie et aux
énergies nouvelles oui c'est peut-être
ça pour moi je fais un peu l'association
à ça mon niveau en place une nouvelle
proposition du gouvernement pour les
jeunes qui sont très en cours de
formation qui n'ont pas su ce fini leur
scolarité ou des choses comme ça on peut
lire qu on met les gens un peu en
alternance pour le principe du point il
faut pas aider tout le temps faut que
les gens se débrouiller un petit peu et
puis faut arrêter cet assistanat quoi
voilà ce que cet assistanat on voit à
quoi ça nous conduit depuis depuis cette
époque solution c'est faut y aller faut
se battre au travail et voilà c'est pas
de l'assistanat qui permettra de sortir
de là quoi je crois qu'il y en a eu
quelques-uns de signer maintenant je dis
faut voir et je voudrais pas que ça soit
comme les et sempiternel contrat qu'on
était fait avant c'est à dire qu'une
fois qu'ils ont fait les deux ans trois
ans on les laisse tomber
ah ça c'est intéressant une fois qu'ils
ont fait les deux ans trois ans est-ce
qu'on va les laisser tomber
alors il n'y a pas d'obligation
d'embauché à l'issue de six emplois
d'avenir
mais justement l'esprit de ces emplois
d'avenir c'est de ne pas les laisser
tomber de préparer la suite
donc dans ce cadre là il est confié aux
missions locales
une tâche nouvelle qui va être le suivi
de ces jeunes en emploi en liaison
permanente avec le jeune avec le tuteur
avec le responsable de la structure qui
l'accueille pour d'une part élaborer un
plan de formation plan de formation qui
sera réajusté au cours de l'emploi
d'avenir en fonction des opportunités
des tâches qui pourraient être confiées
aux jeunes et puis aussi nous devons
faire un bilan deux mois avant la fin de
l'emploi d'avenir pour voir quelles sont
les opportunités qui sont proposées aux
jeunes
est-ce que de rester dans la structure
où il n'y a pas de perspective et dans
ce cas là pour travailler avec lui sur
sa recherche d'empreintes futur aucun
vrai encadrement de la part des missions
locales il y aura aussi une rallonge
budgétaire qui sera accordée par le
gouvernement 38 millions d'euros pour
les différentes missions locales c'est
de l'argent qui va vous servir à quoi
c'est de l'argent que 30 millions de
mains soit peu 51 millions
et c'est de l'argent qui va nous servir
à créer un poste parce que là on est
vraiment dans une mission nouvelle qui
confier aux missions locales qui va
demander une vraie technicité parce que
tout le volet offre de formation va être
assez complexe il va falloir mobiliser
tous les dispositifs de formation que ça
soit ceux du conseil régional que ça
soit c'est de la formation continue que
ça soit l'offre du cnfpt pour la
fonction publique et il va falloir
vraiment bien connaître ça donc c'est
pour ça que là on va créer un poste
quand j'aurai un peu plus d'informations
sur début de mai parenthèses par rapport
au micro trottoir si vous étiez avec
nous il ya quelques instants
on a entendu une personne dans le micro
trottoir et évoqué l' assistanat
faudrait juste vous faire réagir par
rapport à ça ben je crois que justement
on n'est pas du tout j'avais trop
d'athis trop d'assistanat et qu'il
fallait que les jeunes aussi se
débrouille tout seul voilà pour résumer
la pensée on n'est vraiment pas dans
d'assistanat on est dans un vrai emploi
contrat de travail 35 heures par semaine
le jeune est mis en situation de
production
voilà et
et on se préoccupe et de l'avenir c'est
à dire que c'est pas juste un fait
d'aider parce que trop souvent les
jeunes quand ils sont en cdd
eh bien ils vont jusqu'au terme de cette
épuipe ans après la suite avec l'espoir
d'être gardés mais là ils sont un poids
et on voit plus loin que le terme de jeu
emplois d'avenir
actuellement deux emplois d'avenir qui
ont été signés cet attrape c'était la
semaine dernière on parle de 1600 pour
l'ensemble du département c'est possible
c'est réalisable
ça fait à peu près de 200 sur 50 ans
alors c'est un objectif ambitieux il
faut pas tout attendre des emplois
d'avenir si on peut la mission locale de
saint quentin on a chaque année environ
1000 jeunes qui trouva un emploi durable
donc de sens ça sera des opportunités
supplémentaires à proposer à ces jeunes
après ça me semble réaliste on va
falloir compter sur les collectivités
territoriales sur les associations je
pense qu'un certain nombre
d'associations qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas
de salarié pour se dire que c'est
l'occasion de professionnaliser leurs
bénévoles et de leur offrir un vrai
statut un vrai contrat de travail
ça va monter tranquillement en puissance
du au cours de l'année 2013
ça ne paraît pas déraisonnable de se
régénérer et j'aimerais bien qu'ils ont
des 250 et 300 lie actuellement environ
une vingtaine un petit peu moins 15 20
postes en type emplois d'avenir sont
sont proposés à travers la mission
locale de 50 ans lui aujourd'hui on a
une dizaine de postes à pourvoir très
rapidement et puis une dizaine de postes
en projet sur début 2013 c'est donc pour
plus de renseignements on vous renvoie
vers cette mission locale de saint
quentin en yvelines et de ses environs
françois chaumette
merci d'être venu sur le plateau il
était l'invité de cette première partie
du 7-8 ans 7,8 qui va se poursuivre au
programme musique hard rock et puis
chorale ukrainienne également aimé on
parlera également du sidaction journée
de lutte mondiale ce sera le 1er
décembre pour le moment vous allez
découvrir le portrait de thibaut ruggeri
à 30 ans ce chef de l'école lenôtre à
plaisir participera à la fin du mois de
janvier aux championnats du monde et des
cuisiniers nous avons suivi la
préparation de ces plats anthony rech
dont les allées de ce magasin sis
ruggieri finalise son menu le mélange
des saveurs et la mise en avant des
aliments reste la priorité du jeune
candidat français aux championnats du
monde des cuisines
je suis plutôt minimaliste en fait dans
des associations de saveurs
je trouve que le mérite d'un cuisinier
c'est de partir d'une pomme de terre ou
d'une carotte et d'en faire quelque
chose de bon sens je suis pas fan des
associations exotiques ou dire en as mis
du chocolat pour mettre du chocolat pour
moi ça n'a pas de sens
lors de la finale du bocuse d'or le jury
observera tout à la loupe du choix des
produits au marché aux gaspillages en
cuisine en passant par la complicité
entre thibault ruggieri et sakho me
julie lumeau une fois le caddie rempli
départ pour l'atelier le chef de l'école
lenôtre de plaisir se met pour la
première fois dans les conditions du
concours
au menu de la finale la préparation de
14 assiette de turbo et un grand plat de
boeuf qui doivent rappeler la france le
tout en cinq heures et demie en moyenne
la chose donc on va faire un service
traiteur falloir envoyer trente couverts
donc donc dressé dressé au monté en
température
malgré l'agitation qui règne dans
l'atelier
le muguet voix de 30 ans reste
imperturbable c'est quelqu'un qui subit
rarement l'émotion donc automatiquement
je le fait qu'il ya beaucoup de chefs
qui va être présent beaucoup de bruit
beaucoup l'ignorent ce problème thibault
ruggieri a découvert la cuisine à l'âge
de 11 ans en inventant comme il
l'appelle son gâteau poubelles à base de
cap car celui qui milite pour une
cuisine improvisée aime prendre des
risques et fait revenir c'est filet de
turbot à la poêle chaque geste est
précis étudiés pour que le plat devienne
une oeuvre d'art
et après une heure et demie de travail
le turbo à la grenobloise se révèle être
un feu d'artifice de saveur j'aime bien
la répartition des saveurs j'aime bien
je trouve que les trois on a dû
rassurant on a de caraméliser un peu
doué on a du bouillon très léger un peu
boisée avec la truck sa sommes plus
beaucoup
rendez-vous le 30 janvier pour la
version finale